the current retirement situation in
america is an outright crisis literally
people aren't gonna have enough money to
retire if we look here at this chart 52
of americans say that they're behind in
the retirement savings it's a massive
massive number and even more concerning
is 16 don't even know where they stand
and only 11 claim that they're actually
ahead of their plan on retirement
savings this is not a good situation but
not only is the retirement situation bad
in america on top of that we went ahead
and we created pension plans with the
idea that employees and employers would
go ahead and contribute to this fund
that an investment team would invest the
capital they would grow it over time and
when the employee got to retirement age
all of a sudden that investment team
would have the funds ready to go ahead
and continue to pay them a set amount
every single year that they were in
retirement when we think about how bad
public pension funds have actually
performed they've really lagged easy
indicators like the s p 500 or other
benchmarks if we ask somebody like
richard ennis he's got this great quote
in a recent article where he stated that
the bottom line on public fund
performance is that underperformance of
152 basis points per year on the 4.5
trillion dollars in assets translates to
an outright waste of stakeholder value
of 68 billion dollars annually which is
a figure that he finds absolutely
astonishing now there's been some major
major issues the birth rates down
meaning that less people are entering
the workforce meaning that there's less
money actually being contributed to
these pension plans and also people are
living longer lives meaning that there's
more time spent in retirement so that
it's a bigger draw on those pension
plans because of both of these causes
pension plans are in trouble in the
united states many of them are
underfunded they don't have enough money
to pay the liabilities or those future
promises to retirees and so they've got
to do something whether you're an
individual and you're behind on your
retirement savings or you have none at
all or we go ahead and we look at their
pension plans in america they're both in
a really really bad situation now back
in december of 2018 i wrote a letter
publicly and i said that every pension
plan in america should go ahead and buy
bitcoin my argument was that bitcoin was
an asymmetric asset that it was
non-correlated and then if pension plans
went ahead and they bought just one
percent of their assets in bitcoin and
bitcoin then went ahead and increased
significantly they could increase their
assets by two and a half 10 or even 25
percent depending on how high bitcoin's
price went it's not every day that
pension plans actually find an
asymmetric asset that would help them go
ahead and recover from the underfunded
status they currently sit at now most
pension plans didn't go ahead and do
this a couple did including fairfax
county public police pension plan and
also the fairfax employee retirement
system but outside of a couple of those
pension plans there really wasn't anyone
who went ahead and did it and so
ultimately you as an individual you have
to take matters into your own hands and
today fidelity one of the leading asset
managers in the world with trillions of
dollars under management they announced
that they are going to allow their 20
000 plus various corporations they work
with to allow individual employees to
put bitcoin in their 401k and retirement
plans now this is a huge deal because
ultimately the second that employees are
going to be able to put bitcoin in their
own retirement accounts it means that
they're able to benefit from a
decentralized digital currency that is
compounded annually at 150 percent for
the last decade and it has asymmetry
available that can't be replicated with
cash gold or bonds and so ultimately
giving people the choice
not the requirement to put bitcoin in
their retirement account it's going to
be good for the individual it's going to
be a great talent and retention tool for
the corporations and ultimately it's
going to be great for retirees because
it'll allow them to protect their
purchasing power and their wealth over
long periods of time if we look at
somebody like dave gray at fidelity
about what the importance of putting
bitcoin in these retirement accounts
ends up being he stated that there's a
need for a diverse solutions for their
investors they fully expect that
cryptocurrency is going to shape the way
future generations think about investing
for the near term and long term i tend
to agree with dave that this is just the
start of a massive decades-long trend
all these young people they don't want
bonds or gold or cash
they simply want to go ahead and hold
the hardest money that's ever been
created now i'm not saying that fidelity
is the first one to do this they're just
the first major retirement platform to
go ahead and make this decision but
there's companies like choice by kingdom
trust bitcoin ira and many others who
have already pioneered this idea but the
second that fidelity enters the market
and is able to bring this functionality
and this offering to literally millions
and millions and millions of employees
across the united states it's a pretty
big deal it's also great for the bitcoin
market itself when you have fixed supply
asset like bitcoin and you drastically
increase accessibility and demand it's
likely to be good for the price which
has this self-fulfilling aspect if lots
and lots more people put bitcoin into
their retirement accounts
then ultimately that ends up being good
for bitcoin's price and if it ends up
being good for bitcoin's price means it
ends up being good for retirees which
drives more people to do it as well
ultimately bitcoin has a positive
feedback loop and fidelity just opened
one of the floodgates they'll take some
time to onboard companies to educate
their employees and to start actually
rolling out this optionality into their
various retirement programs but i think
this is massive news so one of the
largest asset managers in the world go
ahead and say let's get bitcoin into the
retirement accounts of all of our
customers i think we'll look back a
decade from now and we'll say this was
one of the major inflection points that
drove bitcoin to mass adoption hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you're subscribed
like the video and see you next time